good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-738
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
scp-738 is to be kept in three linked
sealed chambers with armed guards and a
remote detonation system at all times as
well as constant full audio visual
surveillance due to the variety and
strength of observed interactions with
scp-738
and the unknown limits of scp-738 the
following procedures are to be strictly
followed
when scp-738 is not in use its
components must be kept one to each
chamber mechanical means built into the
containment area are to be used to
assemble and disassemble scp-738
should mechanical assembly means fail
then testing is to be cancelled until an
engineer fitted with an explosive collar
can be sent in to repair the systems
said engineer is to be detonated upon
any attempt to interact with any
component of scp-738
should medical disassembly fail preset
shaped charges shall be used to
disassemble scp-738
the system should then be repaired and
reset by a single engineer fitted with
an explosive collar
all d-class personnel used to test the
device must be mildly intellectually
disabled are of comparably impaired
cognitive function and then must be
fitted with an explosive collar this is
in order to prevent them from learning
too much about scp-738
and possibly using scp-738 in a way that
is detrimental to the foundation
class d personnel with iqs over 60 and
all other personnel are not allowed into
the room containing scp-738
class-d personnel are allowed into the
room containing scp-738 for
experimentation only and are to be
provided with continual instruction by
research personnel
description
scp-738 consists of three components a
matched set of mahogany furniture
including one desk currently labeled
scp-738-1 one strike-backed chair
currently labeled
scp-738-2 and one ornate throne-style
office chair labeled
scp-738-3 all with brass embellishments
and royal purple velvet padding
the effect begins when a sentient entity
sits in
scp-738-2 in front of scp-738-1
with
scp-738-3 resting behind scp-738-2
the cameras show
scp-738-3 moving during the effect
frequently leaning back into a relaxed
state as well as moving closer to or
further away from
scp-738-2 ii occasionally
scp-738-3 is moved in front of scp-738-2
furthermore cameras show papers and
folders containing papers leaving
scp-738 once drawers the papers are made
of a parchment a quill pen and a bottle
of ink emerged from the long drawer the
pen will write on the parchment
audio recorders record a distorted voice
speaking this voice will make offers and
promises attempting to tempt the
occupant of
scp-738-2 meaning has been extracted
from the spoken voice if in this time
the entity sitting in
scp-738-2 makes a request then the
tempting and offers will cease there
will be a pause and a price will be
stated this can be bargained with
however the voice will insist on other
prices of equal value occasionally when
a request is made the voice will respond
by telling the requester that they do
not want the object enough or that they
are obviously requesting the object for
someone else to get around paying full
price
in which case the request is not
fulfilled this occurs most frequently
for requests that can affect other
people or can transfer possession
accepting the deal causes the
agreed-upon wish or command to be
fulfilled to the letter but not past the
letter furthermore it will cause the
occurrences stated in the price to be
paid the entity has actively stated that
occurrences in the price are intended to
cause an amount of emotional and or
physical pain to the amount that the
requester desires what they request how
parody is calculated is at present
unknown the price has also been stated
to be independent of any pain caused by
fulfilling the request see the test log
for examples of prices paid and requests
made
as a final note personnel in the chair
have reported seeing an entity sitting
in scp-738-3
however all attempts to observe this
entity when not seated in scp-738-2
have failed and further descriptions of
the entity are inconsistent between
sessions even with multiple sessions
with the same person when asked about
this the entity claims to be the same
entity each time some frequent
descriptions of the entity include
seductive and charming sessions with the
same person that are close in time
report similar or identical entity
appearances sessions with different
people that are close in time report
different entities appearances
descriptions of the voice do not match
the voice recorded on the equipment
addendum 738 1
history
scp-738 was recovered from the office of
a catholic cardinal after his death
he had received it as a gift from the
pope for extraordinary services from the
vatican archives the foundation became
aware of scp-738 after
with
dead and his will contested in the
aftermath of the event foundation
personnel acquired the desk foundation
agents in the vatican reported
recovering some of the documents
surrounding
scp-738
addendum 738 2
test results
test 1 researchers sits in scp-738-2
and waits
results researcher reports several
attempts made to coerce him into a deal
with deals including love of the woman
he wants an object that would make him a
well-respected researcher and the
granting of o5 status startled
researcher leaves scp-738-2
leaves room recordings follow statements
provided researcher reports
disappearance of the entity followed by
return of pen paper and folders to
drawers using cameras speed of object
return clocked at over 120 meters per
second researcher reports seeing a man
in a red and gold business suit
test 2 personnel d26 sat on scp-738-2
analysis performed upon papers and
documents
results spectral analysis has confirmed
that the parchment is human skin the
feather in the quill pen comes from an
unidentified bird subject offered
freedom is told that the price is death
of his best friend d26 laughed and
agreed then vanished d26 was recaptured
five hours later documents written in
english d26 involved in test reported
seeing a beautiful and seductive woman
test 3 personnel 6597
a non-native english speaker sits in
scp-738-2
results papers written in
d6597's native language as is spoken
communication d-6597
offered the power to never be held in a
cell again price is stated to be
memories of
d6597's mother day 6597 accepts offer
after acceptance
resulting in the deaths of 12 guards and
d6597
test 4 personnel 8846
dyslexic and seriously intellectually
disabled sits in scp-738-2
results the language on the parchment
appeared to be crude pictograms
representing the deal though some words
in english were represented in the
parchment in general the english was
unrelated to the pictures they were
under and frequently insult
d8846's intelligence and state that the
entity is uncertain of how much of this
d8846 understands
d8846 was offered a sloppy joe price was
stated to be mopsy a toy that d-8846 had
been allowed to smuggle into the
foundation
d-8846 accepted and food was
materialized upon the desk along with
antique silverware fine china plate and
crystal glass sippy cup with wine
colored grape juice
d8846 shows great distress upon
discovering that mopsy was missing after
finishing meal
d-8846 reports seeing a large pink
rabbit after deal was complete and
d-8846 left the chair recorders picked
up a sigh voice print of psy does not
match d8846's voice
test 4 follow-up d8846 issued toy
exactly identical to mopsy result as
soon as d8846 named the toy mopsy it
vanished
d8846 showed great emotional distress
test 5 destruction testing
result
explosive fire gunshot mechanical wood
chipper fail direct attack upon desk
with axe leaves a single gash with depth
of three millimeters and results in
as well as death of attacking personnel
gash remains in desk video logs show
gash healing at a rate of 1 micrometer
per day
test 6 researcher sits in scp-738-2
asks what are you
result entity taking the appearance of a
large snake states i'm sorry it's
against policy to divulge personal
details but may i interest you in
researchers stood from the chair shaking
and ending the session researcher was
then placed in mental institution 5
awaiting review due to information
revealed by offer
test 7 sheldon katz esquire senior
counsel with the foundation's legal
department
result at commencement of tests mr katz
presented the entity with a notarized
apostled affidavit stating that he was
participating in the test on his own
behalf and not as an agent for the
foundation approximately 41 hours after
the commencement of the test mr katz
lapped into unconsciousness due to
exhaustion mr katz described the
appearance of the entity as identical to
his first-year contracts professor from
law school but he declined to describe
the nature of the offer that had been
made he reported that just prior to his
blacking out he had been in the midst of
negotiating a precise technical
definition of the word shall cat stated
that the current working draft of the
agreement that he and the entity had
been drafting was at least 900 pages
long at that moment exclusive of
exhibits and schedules and that he
regretted not keeping a copy for his
form file a red leather envelope
smelling of sulfur was found on mr
katz's person which contained a
handwritten note reading please come
back any time i hadn't had so much fun
in years mr katz has requested
reassignment
remaining tests require level 4
clearance or higher to view until
declassification is complete
addendum 738 3
notes
in recent testing offers have been made
directly to the researchers who were
telling the subject what to do recommend
cessation of all testing 052
so i know you're all thinking it but i'm
just gonna say it yes of course the
lawyer was the only person who got along
with this entity
of course anyway
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to alla treon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
octo potato football match
hms lily
they the almighty fish
scio dio dimnadus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you